a multi-billion dollar crypto bank is
collapsing and i'm here to explain why
celsius celsius celsius celsius celsius
celsius network celsius networks this
platform is celsius network definitely
is one of the big ones in in the crypto
space joining me now is celsius founder
and ceo alex mashinsky the core business
is to challenge conventional banking
where holders can find decent yield at a
time when traditional savings accounts
pay almost nothing how is it that by
doing nothing i can hold the usd
stablecoin
and earn close to 10
let me stop you right there
you can't it turns out today we're
answering all the questions what is
celsius why is it collapsing and
why don't they just convert it to
fahrenheit honestly well i'm here to
answer celsius is a place where you can
deposit your cryptocurrencies in
exchange for interest payments and they
will turn around and give out loans uh
and charge interest on that as well and
if that sounds like a bank to you
depositing and lending money i should
clear that part up right away celsius
says they're not a bank because banks
are bad banks are not your friends we
all know that
and we decided to create a replacement
for the banking system right something
that acts in your best interest a place
where you can actually have your money
work for you not just you work for your
money and basically three years since we
launched the product we've paid a
billion dollars back to the community
wow that guy you just heard speaking is
alex mashinsky and nobody hates banks
more than this guy i mean look at his
shirt how could his company which lends
money and takes deposits be a bank when
he has a shirt that says banks are not
your friends weird foreshadowing
actually in fact before we jump into
this whole thing i need to tell you how
much alex hates banks he hates them so
much he says that banking and securities
laws shouldn't apply to his company
quote banking and securities laws
shouldn't apply to celsius because
cryptocurrencies are commodities this is
from a great article by bloomberg and he
says quote like a neighbor who borrows a
cup of sugar then later gives back a cup
and a tablespoon more that's right the
normal rules shouldn't apply to him why
would you regulate this humble little
sugar lender well i can think of one
reason maybe it has something to do with
the 25 billion cups of sugar that
celsius has under management wait i'm
sorry dollars i got a little confused
there and yeah actually it's not cups of
sugar they're lending so much as it is
digital dollars which it's kind of hard
to say that lending digital dollars and
lending regular dollars are not pretty
similar things again i think most people
would say the rules should apply to them
especially since celsius is now
collapsing and we do not know yet
whether it will survive this crash or
what will happen to its 25 billion cups
of sugar but of course the big question
is what is causing this collapse well it
turns out for the past few months people
have been worried about celsius's
ability to repay customers back their
withdrawals partially because of the
insane yields that they were paying out
for example if you were to deposit like
a dollar at a bank you'd get a fraction
of a percent of interest every year on
the other hand if you deposited one
tether or usdc at celsius they were
paying
nine percent per year on your money
that's the same amount of money and
celsius is paying out a hundred times
the interest rate on that exact same
deposit basically and the question is
how is that possible right is this thing
too good to be true and if it is when is
it going to collapse well the founder
mashinsky has been telling everyone that
it's not too good to be true in actual
fact the reason this is possible is
because
banks equal bad and celsius equal good
he's quoted as saying it's the
traditional finance system that's
ripping people off by taking their
deposits using them to make money and
then claiming it can only pay tiny
interest rates somebody is lying
mashinsky said either the bank is lying
or celsius is lying oof
that aged poorly didn't it because
despite him claiming that everything was
fine things under the surface weren't
actually so great see at least in theory
the idea of celsius isn't like totally
insane right banks do give tiny interest
rates compared to what they make and
celsius was charging fairly high
interest rates to borrow their crypto
like to borrow a stablecoin they would
charge 12
which is more than they were paying to
deposit it but the real problem is that
no bank or new age finance company can
ever loan out a hundred percent of what
they have as deposits the reason is that
if you lint out every dollar you took in
you have nothing left to pay withdrawals
back with and so you're left in this
sort of conundrum on the one hand you
want to loan out as much as possible to
get the interest to pay your depositors
but on the other hand you need to keep
enough on hand to pay for withdrawal and
that's all money that you're not making
interest on which makes this whole thing
kind of a weird balancing act lend too
much you can't meet withdrawals lend too
little you're losing money every month
now perhaps to solve this money problem
celsius created their own crypto token
called sell which people could invest in
this token in theory was supposed to
lube the whole system up and make it
work smoothly like a finely tuned engine
it could provide liquidity where they
needed it actually they literally
described the system as a wheel
according to machinski a wheel of
fortune that keeps on giving according
to him this was celsius's main business
plan flywheel token economics he called
it issue loans collect interest give it
to the people lend coins collect
interest on coins buy celsius distribute
to members you get the idea money goes
up forever well right up until it
doesn't because in case you haven't
noticed
it's winter in june i mean
checkmate climate scientists we are in a
crypto winter okay and markets are all
down and all of a sudden people start to
get a little worried money doesn't just
go up and so some withdrawals start to
begin
at first everything's fine the financial
times reported a billion dollars flowed
out from march to may
no big deal right but as things
continued things got a little shaky for
celsius because all of a sudden everyone
sees luna collapse in may which was
because of unsustainable yields and
you're looking at celsius like
that kind of looks like the same thing
but then worst of all the cell token
which they created started to plummet
now this is where things get bad because
the cell token is like the grease in
this flywheel remember it was how they
were going to get out of their jam they
could just always sell their little
token and get the money to pay back
anything maybe they had some deposits
locked up right but if their cell token
becomes nearly worthless all of a sudden
small jams become much more dangerous so
things are getting worse and compounding
this problem a lot of deposits of theirs
are locked up for example their ethereum
deposits were locked in eth2 now this
part of the story gets a little
complicated so we're kind of grazing
past some stuff that i may get to in a
full postmortem i'm doing later but all
you need to know for now is that they
didn't have enough liquidity and they
started to take loans to pay back for
withdrawals this was documented by the
crypto researcher dirty bubble media he
would track the crypto that flowed into
their wallets and started to notice that
big exchanges like ftx started sending
50 million dollars in usdc to celsius
all of a sudden and he would post this
for everyone to see and it sort of
became a vicious cycle the more the
pressure mounted on celsius the more
celsius would take out loans or try to
find ways to pay for withdrawals but
then people would see that and post it
on twitter which would cause people to
panic thinking that celsius was unbacked
and as a result even more withdrawals
would come which would again make them
need to go out for loans i think you get
the idea sort of the opposite of
mashinsky's flywheel and eventually all
of this became too much for them
officially on june 12 2022 celsius
paused all withdrawals swaps and
transfers the idea here being if they
can recoup some of the crypto they have
locked up elsewhere they can actually
pay for withdrawals and i get that this
may have been necessary but this is sort
of like the pilot in the aircraft saying
don't panic but i'm putting a pause on
the engines for a second i i mean
everyone's going to immediately panic
and the cell token plummeted another 50
in one hour from there this obviously
compounds the solvency issue further
because any cell tokens that they have
are even more worthless not to mention
it's unclear whether celsius has all the
money to pay back investors so maybe
they're just putting a pause on the
inevitable meanwhile people start to
crawl around the terms of conditions at
this time they signed up to and they
found something quite worrying they
found the bankruptcy clause that was in
this centralized like bank that's not a
bank and listen to what it says in the
event that celsius becomes bankrupt
enters liquidation or is otherwise
unable to pay its obligations any
eligible digital assets used in the
earned services
or as collateral under the borrow
service may not be recoverable so it
turns out that when a bank that's not a
bank takes your money
the rules don't apply to them the same
way i mean don't you get it when you
were giving them your hard-earned crypto
it was more like you were lending them
some sugar cubes and i don't mean to
make light of this or anything but their
position is so clearly silly although i
want to be clear that celsius i hope
they make it through this not because
they deserve to but because the
investors who have their life savings
stuck in there deserve to keep their
money i mean if one thing became very
clear to me while researching the story
it's how many people dump their life
savings into this once again coming from
the bloomberg article quote as part of a
contest in which customers shared their
celsius story many said they entrusted
celsius with their life savings one said
he took out home equity and cashed in
his work pension and his savings for his
kids education to put the money into the
company accounts i mean this is rough
guys it reminds me a lot of the luna
situation where people were just dumping
ridiculous amounts of their money into
it even a pension fund in canada
actually participated in a funding round
for celsius so they're exposed to this
whole thing too
it just looks really bad and so for all
of those people's sake
i hope that celsius isn't what it looks
like which is
bankrupt which is a weird thing to say
about something that isn't a bank
anyways that is the story of celsius
i'll be giving a full post postmortem
coming soon but i wanted to give some
clarity around this subject for those of
you who are listening to the news right
now hearing what's going on thanks for
watching subscribe if you enjoyed it and
i will see you in the next one